this is me John Perry using homemade
Playdoh to measure the volume of the eye
socket of an elongated skull from
paracas per why to test the claim by
mystery researcher Brian Forester the
eye sockets are at least 50% larger than
normal that can't be explained through
head binding or anything like that that
has to be genetic Brian believes the
skull on the left is not human I doubt
that that the ancestors of these people
are what we call Homo sapiens in the
past my nephew and I did a water
displacement experiment to test Brian's
claim that the baracus skulls are 25%
larger than human skulls it turned out
that Brian was wrong at least he was
wrong about the skulls we measured
Jackson and I were only able to measure
casts not the original thing but locals
in Peru directly measured the inside of
the largest skull in their Museum they
also found like we did that even though
these skulls are longer than normal
they're also narrower the size of their
brain is human but what about their eye
sockets and other claims Brian has made
well Buckle in my friends it's time for
a little science today's video is
another on a topic that's very near and
dear to my heart the elongated skulls of
Peru now many of you know that I did a
series of videos about these skulls
several years ago people on the internet
were claiming that these skulls belong
to aliens the mainstream explanation for
these skulls is that these are normal
people just regular South American
people who practiced skull binding
artificial cranial deformation Brian
Forester has written a book about these
and he says that some of the parus
skulls some of the elongated skulls from
Peru probably are just normal cranial
binding but other ones in particular the
one that I have he thinks that this is a
different species it's not human the
pictures that I'm showing you here some
of them are from the Mong betu tribe in
Africa that they used to do skull
elongation they stopped I believe in the
' 50s skull elongation has been
happening in different cultures at
different times all throughout history
this person here is from France where
the practice of skull binding was
popular in certain subcultures for a
very long time there's a really
interesting book written in 1931 when
the practice had almost completely died
out it's written by Anthropologist Eric
John dingwall he talks about the
conflict between the country people who
were doing the skull elongation and the
French Elite who wanted to have it
banned because they considered it to be
a form of child mutilation to my
knowledge no one alive today has an
artificially elongated skull this
practice is gone everywhere Brian
Forster he admits that this can happen
that people can do cranial binding but
he does not think that the skull that I
have by the way this skull this is a
replica this is not a real skull this is
a replica but it it is an exact replica
a company called bone clones makes this
and they took the original skull the
same skull that Brian Forester has on
the cover of his book and they made a
cast of it it is accurate to the
millimeter and actually Brian Forester
in his book he is the one who told me
where to buy it this is one of the
skulls that he says is natural it's not
he thinks this is not done through
cranial binding and then there are
websites like gaia.com where they
suggest that this is an alien and yeah
you know if you
don't know anything about human anatomy
if everything you know about human
anatomy and everything you know about
aliens comes from like the cone heads or
uh Star Trek then maybe you could
believe that this is an alien but of
course Brian forcer doesn't believe it's
an alien but Brian claims that even
though these are not aliens he doesn't
think they're human and there are 10
reasons he thinks that they are not
human in the video I did several years
ago with my nephew we tested three of
these 10 claims we checked to see if we
could confirm them and we found that all
three of those were false but people on
YouTube were angry at me they did not
like that they did not think that that
was enough even one guy who's a fan of
my work he was a little bit upset Flint
given YouTuber he says it seems like you
just ignored evidence that didn't follow
your views or the mainstream and
anything that aligned with your views
you used he's accusing me of
cherry-picking the data I said okay well
find every claim that Brian Forester has
made send that to me and will go through
each one of those this full list right
here this full list of 10 claims that
Brian Forester has made this comes from
Flint and several other viewers who gave
me this full list Flint kindly sent me
links to videos where Brian makes each
of these claims so high five to Flint
that was super helpful the point of this
video is not to debunk Brian's claims
it's to test Brian's claims are they
accurate or are they not so that's what
we're going to do today it requires a
little bit of uh rolling up of the
sleeves and I'm actually going to be
doing some experimentation with this
skull replica again this is the exact
skull Brian Forester tells you to buy
it's the cover of his book I'm not
cheating I am using the skull that Brian
Forester himself tells us that we should
use so let's dive
in3 questions about
Evolution with John
Perry evolutionary question number 33
was a new species of human found in Peru
this here is Julio Cesaro he's a pretty
amazing guy he's a native Peruvian the
name that he went by publicly was a
Spanish name but he's actually full
native Peruvian according to what I've
read in his home they spoke the ketua
language which is one of the Native
languages there in Peru as a young child
he also learned Spanish and then later
on he learned English and he ended up
going to Harvard where he studied
archaeology and what he did is he worked
with locals he worked with natives he
discovered the parus culture it's an
amazing culture Advanced surgeries all
sorts of really cool things that they
were doing in this culture and they had
these elongated skulls he did not think
that they were aliens and he did not
think that that these elongations were
caused by some sort of genetic mutation
there actually were people in his day
that that thought that this was a
mutation but Julio was very familiar
with the process of skull elongation in
North America there were Native American
groups that had been doing that they
weren't doing that in his day but when
Europeans made early contact the shinook
natives were doing cradle boarding which
gave them these tall triangle-shaped
heads as I mentioned earlier in France
in Europe people were doing skull
elongation in a different way they would
bind the head right after birth all
around its circumference and that would
cause the head to grow long and skinny
here's a woman in Africa doing a very
similar thing here's what a child looks
like this person is old enough to no
longer have to wear The Binding it's
bizarre huh it looks very uncomfortable
here's a woman with this done and it it
looks good here's another woman and her
baby doing this he's not wearing the
straps right now taking a break from it
it looks like and here's an older woman
with the skull elongation it's a really
wild practice it really is amazing to me
to look at these skulls and to know that
you know look at how plastic the human
body is look look at how much intense
modification can happen I mean look at
it look at it from this angle it looks
huge and again because they look so
bizarre people in Julio's time thought
that they might be some genetic
variation but he did not he believed
they were the result of normal skull
binding Brian forcer does not believe
that Julio is correct and he gives 10
reasons the first one we'll look at
today is his claim that the eye sockets
are about 50% larger than in normal
humans the fact that the eye sockets are
at least 50% larger than normal that
can't be explained through uh head
binding or anything like that that has
to be genetic 50% larger what does Brian
even mean by this it's well documented
that skull binding in France stretched
the eye sockets vertically causing eyes
to bulge slightly you can see this very
clearly in photos of head binding in
African children it's super obvious in
babies it looks painful but in adults it
seems the eye sockets are stretched
vertically as well when Brian says the
sockets are 50% larger surely he's
talking about overall volume a change in
iocket height is to be expected with
skull binding but not a change in volume
if the elongated skulls really have more
volume that really would act as proof
that there is a genetic component to
these elongated skulls it would act as
proof that these are not the result of
normal head binding so let's do an
experiment to measure the volume of
these eye sockets so what I've done is
I've got some uh some dough here it's
just flour and water and salt little
little Play-Doh and we're just going to
test the volume of the elongated skull
and then see if the eyeball from the
elongated skull would fit into the skull
of a normal
human first I need to put a little bit
of powder in there so that it doesn't
stick CU you know it's just water and
wheat and let's see if is this big
enough
then I kind of got it on the first
estimate the first
try uh I want to have
it I want to have it bulge a little bit
let me add a little bit more dough to
this
just a little bit more
dough to get the volume of that
eye okay so here we go put that in
there and that's pretty good
that's maybe a little bit maybe it's a
little bit too big let me pinch some of
that
off and roll it
here so we're just trying to
get the
volume of this eye socket because again
you could stretch something upwards by
skull binding but you shouldn't be
increasing the overall volume of that
eye so there we go there you can see
that I filled that eye
socket I'm smashing it in firmly here so
make sure to go into the all the
crevices on the inside of the
skull of the eye socket that
is and there we go we got a nice nicely
filled eye socket no tricks here no
editing let me pull this out
and in one quick
move push it over to the normal hum
skull and see if it fits in
there
and look at that sure
enough that fits perfect in fact the eye
socket of the non-elongated skull is a
slightly larger volume look we're not
it's not sticking out near nearly as
much as it did it's not bulging out like
it did on the flattened skull what I
think is going on here is that when you
do skull binding it actually pulls
everything up and back a little bit and
it probably actually stops the eye
socket from growing to its full depth
the eye sockets on these elongated
skulls are actually smaller than they
are in normal people because of the
skull binding process now it's Al
possible that it's just because this
person was smaller than this person and
that's why the uh the eye socket is
slightly smaller so there is normal
human variation of eye size but this is
definitely not a 50% larger uh eye
socket in the elongated skulls that is
just a completely false claim and again
Brian for he never made any measurements
he just made this claim and expect
expected people to believe it we've
tested it here the best way that we
could by actually measuring the volume
differences and it turns out that his
claim is indeed
false now claim number two Brian
Forester claims that there are holes on
the back of these skulls that are not
found in normal humans so here's an
example of that hole uh this one only
has one some of them he says have two
and then there are also these two holes
in the back of the skull here which are
a genetic characteristic this is the
claim that my nephew and I looked into
during our earlier series it is true
that many of the elongated skulls have
holes in the back but these are normal
in humans not all people have them but
so many people do scientists have given
these holes a name they are called
parietal Fen you can read all about them
in anatomy textbooks or in the
scientific paper I have right here on
screen the fact that elongated skulls
have parietal foramen is not an anomaly
indicating they are a new species
Brian's second claim in our list is also
false his third claim is that the
elongated skulls do not have Forman
ovali and then also there are things
called Forman ovali I believe they're
called which are up and inside here in
the skull that is where nerve and blood
flow comes out to feed the face and that
gives us our facial expressions they
seem to be absent in the paracas
elongated skulls which means their
facial expression
would have been very different from us
which again is an abnormality the Fran o
Val are these little holes on the bottom
of the skull that are colored in green
right here he claims that the elongated
skulls do not have these if I look at my
elongated skull if I flip it over you
can see quite clearly that
actually it's right here right there you
have in fact the forino valy so my my
skull has them and if you go and you
look at the actual picture that he has
on his website of his own skulls from
his Museum the ones that he says don't
have them they very clearly do have them
they're right there Brian's thirdd claim
is also false I'm beginning to notice a
pattern here I'm not sure if I'm the
only one but I'm noticing a pattern his
fourth claim is that they are missing A
sagittal suture that all normal humans
have the suture lines here is the suture
running across this way but there is no
sign of the sagittal suture whatsoever
behind me I have a human skull that is
not
elongated this guy here and this is this
person died fairly young uh according to
Bone clones this is this is another
replica from bone clones according to
Bone clones this guy died when he was
maybe uh in his early 30s or so and you
can see that he has on the top of the
skull he has these little
cracks these are called sutures there's
one going across uh the crown of the
head that is called the coronal
suture and then there's this one that
goes backwards that's called the
sagittal suture if you look at the
elongated skull this person does have
the Cor Al suture going across the sides
but they don't have the sagittal suture
that is missing his claim is that that
means that this is not a human but in
reality humans go through a process
called suture obliteration as they age
it doesn't always happen not to everyone
but for a certain percentage of the
population by the age of 40 the sagittal
suture starts to obliterate it starts to
completely fuse to where there's no sign
of it left and by the time you're an old
age it's often gone the obliteration the
full obliteration of the sagittal suture
is a totally normal thing for normal
humans Brian forester's claim is false
next up he says that the fiman Magnum is
oval in the elongated skulls where in
humans it is round also the opening of
the Forin Magnum appears to be oval and
not round as it is in Homo sapiens
sapiens and that's another abnormality
so again here we're looking at a normal
human skull and we're going to look
underneath at the foran Magnum which is
this really large hole here foran means
hole Magnum it's like you know big the
big hole underneath the skull and if we
look at the elongated
skull the first thing that we notice
really is that the elongated skull has a
smaller framan Magnum and sure enough
it's also oval but if you do a quick
search for the normal size and shape
variation of for randman Magnum in
humans you find that both the shape and
and the size is completely normal
different people have different sized
and different shaped foran Magnum this
is just normal human variation Brian's
claim that it is not is again false next
claim their Forman Magnum is further
back than a normal humans in the
original elongated skulls of this area
the foreman Magnum is a full 1 in back
from where it's supposed to be because
with us of course it's at the B bance
point so it's almost in the center but
the original paracas is basically 1 in
backwards so here I have the elongated
skull and if we flip it over we see that
well it actually looks like the framan
Magnum is in the middle it's it's really
it's where it should be why does Brian's
picture look so much different than the
skulls do in real life well it's because
he's holding it at an angle if you hold
the skull like this it does look like
the framan Magnum is positioned in the
far back of the head but that's because
it's being held at a weird angle if we
just hold it at a more reasonable angle
we see that the Forman Magnum is exactly
where it's supposed to be and the
elongated skull you know the back of the
skull has actually been smashed in so it
is a little bit hard to place it if
you're trying to look at the back of the
skull but if you look at this part right
here if you just look at the roof of the
mouth and measure backwards you find
that it's actually in exactly the right
spot it's in the exactly the same spot
as it is in a normal human being not
only is Brian's claim false this is a
classic camera trick claim number seven
their brain cases are 25% larger in
volume than a human's as mentioned in
the intro of this video this claim has
been tested by many people local people
in Peru with access to museum specimens
have directly measured the inside of the
brain cases Jackson and I measured the
total volume of the outside of the cast
cast of an elongated skull the very cast
that Brian tells people to buy in his
book happens to be the cast of the
specimen on the cover of his book all of
the measurements I am aware of have
found that the elongated skulls even
though they are longer than normal they
are also more narrow than normal meaning
the total volume of the brain case
itself it's well within the normal human
range exactly what you would expect with
head binding it's worth pointing out
that Brian so far as I can tell has
never measured the volume of an
elongated skull in fact in his book he
explains how he concluded that the
skulls are 25% larger than normal he
just speculated the volume he even says
it hasn't yet been proven my nephew and
I did a game show episode where we asked
viewers to estimate the volume of
different shaped beer mugs to see if
they can do so accurately so one of
these cups is missing 40 ML and one of
these Cups has an extra 40 ml now just
so you know the coloring here has
nothing to do with an anything I I did
the coloring afterwards
so um don't use that as a hint pause the
video and try to figure this out for
yourself we gave viewers an entire week
to try and figure this out this was the
result 89 people played and every single
one of them got it wrong in fact one
person Miss roshen somehow managed to
get it perfectly wrong humans are
terrible at judging the volume of
irregularly shaped objects by eye
Brian's claim here once again is false
at least he was wrong about the skulls
we measured Brian also claims that the
elongated skulls are heavier than normal
to my knowledge he never gives us any
measurements Brian never tells us how
heavy a skull is supposed to be and he
never tells us how heavy the pacus
skulls are claim number eight the pacus
people were born with elongated skulls
where humans are not Brian doesn't give
us any evidence to back up that claim in
some of his videos and on his tours he
does show small children with elongated
skulls but of course we know from the
photographs of the African group that
does skull elongation people start this
right away and then Brian's claim that
humans are never born with elongated
skulls that claim is actually false it's
actually really common for humans to be
born with elongated skulls if they had a
rough birth in most cases it'll turn
round again here's another example the
reason that happens here's a cast of a
baby skull a newborn skull and you can
see that the skull is made of little
plates and there's soft tissue between
those plates and it's very very pliable
when a baby is first born I should point
out that if you go on the like the alien
UFO websites that talk about elongated
skulls they will tell you that early
explorers found a mummy and inside that
mummy was an unborn child and that
unborn child had an elongated skull
here's the drawing that's presented with
that there are several striking things
about this drawing first of all
obviously drawings are not evidence of
anything but back in those days it was
probably the best that they could do so
we'll give them a pass there but the
skull on this thing does not look like
the skull of a fetus again a fetus is
going to have multiple bone plates in
the head furthermore this supposed fetus
has teeth fetuses don't have teeth so
riddle me this what's more likely these
early explorers discovered an alien
fetus and then lost it all we have now
is this drawing sucks to BS should have
been there or the artist who drew what
he saw didn't remember very well what it
was that he actually saw or they were
shown a child that had already started
head binding and had already grown teeth
I know I have my opinions but what do
you think is more likely so with claim
number eight the first part of that
claim is a little bit dubious I doubt
that all of the pacus people were born
with elongated skulls but any of them
that had a rough birth they might have
been born with slightly elongated skulls
just like normal humans Brian claims
that humans are never born with
elongated skulls and that claim is false
claim number nine a preliminary study
found their DNA is not human if my video
here is the only one you've ever seen of
Brian's work at this point you might be
thinking he's a scam artist in the
videos I make I've actually come across
quite a few scam artists and I don't
think Brian is one of them Gia the
company that interviews him quite often
they are scam artists they are I would
say the used car salesman of woo woo
spiritualism but I do believe Brian is
sincere I think the errors that he makes
are simply because he's so excited about
these elongated skulls it's difficult
for him to think about them critically
and one of the reasons that I say that I
don't think he's actually a scam artist
he's not trying to trick people is
because of the way that he's dealt with
this claim at one point he had some DNA
testing done and afterwards he made a
claim that suggested these things might
have alien DNA he said that the DNA had
mutations in it unknown to any human or
animal but it looks like after making
that claim someone who understands
genetics sat down and talked to him
about it because in the clip I'm about
to show you he corrects himself and his
explanation for what was going on here
is really well done just for some
context here Brian was invited to speak
at a conference during Brian's talk he
did not mention the DNA it seems like he
had already decided that that was
inappropriate and he gets called out for
it here at the end haven't you buried
the
lead the well the thing that stimulated
me and got me motivated to get in touch
with you was the reference that I came
across which says that some genetic
tests that have been
done have found that the DNA and the
skulls
that were quote unknown in any human
primate or animal known so far that's
true that slide unfortunately was
missing but initial DNA
testing uh the has shown that there are
segments of DNA from at least one paraca
skull that doesn't fit Homo
sapiens um or denisovan or any known
humanoid and so that became something
which was blasted around the planet and
of course I was attacked heavily for it
but that is why now we're working with
the Peruvian government and having
multiple samples sent to a genetics
laboratory or in fact
uh the University of California uh
contacted me two days ago and said that
they would do free genetic testing um
for us because this is an incredibly
expensive
procedure uh if you have your blood
sample taken of course you can find out
wherever it is that your ancestors came
from Etc but these people mysteriously
died out 2,000 years ago and DNA breaks
down just like any organic material
would so something which is DNA which is
2,000 years ago required
the most advanced uh uh computer
programming to try to reassemble these
tiny pieces of DNA and that's basically
where where we are at right now Brian
did a great job explaining what's going
on there I couldn't have done better
myself the initial tests that he had
done were just normal DNA tests but his
sample was ancient it had been beaten up
for thousands of years by sunlight and
radiation and just you know the elements
and so of course it had m ations in it
it had DNA breaks in it that no other
human has when Brian was taught how this
works he seems to have accepted it so
claim number n was false and has been
corrected by Brian himself and it has
been replaced with claim number 10
according to Brian some of the DNA
results say that these are normal Native
Americans like you would expect and some
of the DNA tests he had done found hints
of DNA from Europe and from the Middle
East Brian has not released the raw data
from those tests his GoFundMe page does
have a couple of photos from a computer
screen showing what he claims to be some
of the results but none of the raw data
instead he's selling a book about it and
he made some YouTube videos last week I
asked him for the raw data he has not
responded to my request but at any rate
it's not super relevant to this video
remember we started out asking was a new
species discovered in Peru to that the
answer is no but Brian now thinks the
paracas people may have been from the
Middle East given his track record I'm
when I go ahead and take that claim with
a healthy grain of
salt that was a very long video that
was I don't think that people can accuse
me honestly of cherry picking any longer
let me end by just again reminding you
that this summer I will be joining Nancy
on her Evolution tour in Ecuador in the
Amazon jungle we're going to see all
sorts of animals I'm giving multiple
lectures on Evolution and I really hope
that you join me for that because it's
going to be a ton of fun go to evot
tour. info for details so long for now